from the outside looking in you guys
just the funniest cutest couple so what
is one thing that would be sort of
surprised to learn about you guys we
sleep naked but you probably but you
probably already knew that
maybe this will surprise you he's like
very crazy aggressive cuddler like wants
to hold very hard oh and I'm more of the
one that's like I get very hot oh very
hot so I'm rolling to the other side of
the bed entertainment tonight's big
headline crazy that bastard
sit back buckle up and hold on cuz
Chrissy is confessing all the biggest
beauty regrets she does not want Munna
to repeat over tweezed brows Wow it's
bad I can't believe I got work on this I
wish I could tell kids how much is
riding on your eyebrows for the rest of
your life and you're gonna post some of
those pictures I hope I'm I'm mortified
just to show you as a mom of two Chrissy
says she's ditching all the extra that
includes no more hair extensions cuz I
mean who has time when you've got school
drop-off taking the nut to preschool
basically it's a big hat my little nub
of a ponytail yeah I took all the hair
out I just couldn't like maintain it
anymore I really love having a lip
because then you can just like slap on a
giant pair of sunglasses and no one
knows what's happening under there is
there a social media break in your
future no I can't imagine I'm gonna be
if Twitter ever ends up like MySpace I
don't know what I'll do I caught up with
a 32 year old at the Sephora beauty
convention where she debuted her new
Chrissy cravings collection with Becca
cosmetics and check out little makeup
mogul in the making Luna
why didn't realize we're gonna make
everything smell like a Dilla paint no a
delicious vanilla icing I know we had to
I don't know if I can say this but I
order a time online to for myself like I
don't just that I order it what did you
ordered it yeah yeah I think you have to
support yourself like if you don't
support yourself who's gonna do it
you
[Music]
[Applause]